uh now for more on Israel's imminent
ground war let's bring in former
Pentagon official Elbridge Colby is with
us former Israeli special operator Aaron
con Aaron start with you um all
indications are they've got the green
light it's a go we saw an increase in
activity it with Hezbollah uh on the
border with lodon Israel had already
evacuated 28 uh communities in the area
in the hopes of protecting lives so it
seems if they do begin the ground
incursion into Gaza that there'll be an
increase of military activity in the
north and now we are fighting a twoof
front war and then with the big question
mark does Iran get inv involved your
thoughts uh my thoughts are that uh
Israel's uh this ain't the first time
that we've gotten into it with multiple
countries attacking us from multiple
directions uh there's already action
we've already neutralized a couple of
dozen terrorists on the Northern front
uh we're using drones artillery uh we
got Air Force Special Operations assets
on the ground hitting targets uh with
selectivity regarding Gaza Sean uh you
let me set the table uh uh I believe
that Israel is going to go into Gaza and
the reason why is because they have to
and I'm going to bring you back to 1997
during the Oslo Accords we made peace we
sat down our then prime minister rabine
who was a treasur one of the uh one of
the founders and fathers of modern
Israel who helped turn that desert into
a beautiful country uh believed in peace
it got the Israelis behind him and what
ended up happening was we ended up
disbanding our Elite counterterror
undercover unit that was responsible for
the overall maintenance in Gaza and I
believe it's not the IDF Commander's
fault I believe that it was a uh a
decision that was made in order to try
and make peace at the time it was Arafat
and so we haven't had the ability to get
in there and and and and clear that
fertilizer out so those terrorists don't
keep growing and keep snatching and
grabbing those terrorist leaders and
getting that Intel we need so right now
Israel's got 20 years worth of work that
they have to make up for and it's going
to be bloody it's going to be messy
there's going to be tunnels we got
hostages but you know what like I've
said to you before this is when Israel
comes together the Israelis are smart
Poise audacity and now we're going to
add a little bit of a little bit of
sprinkler or resolve but again I think
you're going to see Israel doing uh what
it does at its finest which is uh being
able to springboard multiple Ops with
selectivity using our incredibly built
out Special Operations apparatus
Elbridge let me go to you it speaks
volumes to me that these foreign leaders
would not meet with uh our own President
Joe Biden when he was in the Middle East
yesterday they they just flat out
rejected him uh it also you know it it
angers me to no end that he is that
naive that he can give six billion to
the Iranians and he's pushing Israel so
hard on the issue of Aid to the people
of uh the Palestinian people knowing
full well or if he doesn't know there's
a level of ignorance that frankly is
unforgivable for a US president but
wanting to give a $100 million in Aid
humanitarian Aid you we all know there's
no way that money is going to
humanitarian Aid that money will end up
in the hands of Hamas and they keep
making the same mistakes over and over
again now if they want to really give
money and they want to ensure it's it's
used for humanitarian purposes maybe
there's checks and balances they can put
in place but I wouldn't give them one
red scent unless and until they released
every single hostage first why do they
why does Joe not try to get anything out
of these people and he's willing to
throw hundreds of millions of dollars at
them well good to be with you Sean on
this on this uh sober night but as it
looks like The Invasion the incursion
into Gaza may may start I think look if
you're thinking about what a what a just
war is or a just cause you look at
what's necessary and the degree of the
provocation and clearly there was the
most abominable provocation in the
unprecedented atrocities in the postwar
era against uh Israelis and there's no
question but that the Israelis you know
from a strategic point of view they have
to go in and have to restore deterrence
uh the famous strategist Claus wood said
you know sometimes you need the flashing
sword of Vengeance and I it's very clear
to me talking to Israeli friends and
watching uh you know online on tv that
people in in Israel feel that kind of uh
Vengeance in a very deep and I think
just way that doesn't mean going in and
you know leveling the whole place for
its own sake but it has to be
thoroughgoing and there has to be the
destruction of the Hamas apparatus and
that is going to be very very difficult
and I think the Biden Administration you
know the vibe you get is they kind of
want to have it both ways they want it
done cleanly but the reality is
unfortunately and tragically there is no
way to do it cleanly and of course Hamas
is the one who set it up that way so I
think this is where we're going to start
to see the dynamic go and where I think
it's very important for United States to
back our very close Ally Israel as it
goes through this very difficult
operation but that that simply has to
happen from both a strategic point of
view and from a you know kind of a
Justice point of view to to to you know
restore some semblance of Justice after
this Abomination what do what are we to
make if I can ask both of you maybe
Eldridge I'll stick with you for a
second here of the Iranian comment that
the time is up that sounds like an
imminent threat of their Poss possible
involvement on top of a two-front war
now we're looking at the number one
state sponsor of Terror threatening
Israel
simultaneously well I thought that was
very concerning I mean my understanding
is the Iranians have been sending
various different messages I I think
what your the correspondent John uh in
in Israel uh said about the The Limited
ability of Iran to directly necessarily
attack Israel but of course above all
Hezbollah but others uh
ter that is very dangerous they have the
military it is although I think most
yeah go ahead they do and I think I
think Hezbollah is of course a catspaw
of there so it's it's almost the same
thing that they could unleash I think
it's going to be very important look the
IDF is is very capable as Mr Cohen was
pointing out they're not asking us to
fight their Wars I think the key thing
is for us to back them up politically
and and wherever possible in terms of
military and financial support let me
ask if I can add to that real quick yeah
please go ahead uh uh a little we have a
little expression and it's beit
do and I'm talking to uh to my uh
Iranian friend Nala you're not out of
our reach you know and to our friend
ishia you know enjoy that six-star hotel
in Cutter
you're not out of our reach either uh
you know we invented uh Pegasus we're
listening to every phone call thousands
of them and uh and and our intelligence
capabilities even though we've got 20
years of catching up to do right now and
tunnels that we got to get through and
hostages that we got to get to this is
what we do we're Masters at this craft
when it comes to hostage rescue Sean and
we're we've got an incredible unit
called Yom which specializes in
explosive ordinance disposal in those
tunnels and all the time that we have
right now that we're sitting on right
now that's a friend it's not a friend to
the hostages but it's a friend to that
direct action against Hamas and there's
about 40,000 of them waiting in there
but the Israelis are getting focused and
they're getting prepared right now so
again none of you guys are without are
not within our reach uh to Mr Nala
and K so you know we've got a capability
to get to everybody yeah uh I've known
the Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu
for almost three decades uh Aaron and
one thing I can say with 1,00% certainty
that one front War Two Front War Iranian
involvement you're right BB Netanyahu
will do what it will take to Pro protect
and preserve Israel and if Iran wants to
pick that fight does I predict they're
going to lose in the South they're going
to lose in the north and if the Iranians
want to get involved Israel will do
whatever is necessary that they remain a
state
that's
it and it won't matter what the rest of
the world thinks at that point you agree
with me Aaron last word I agree I agree
with you 100% BB Netanyahu doesn't mess
around he was an officer he was on one
of the incredible raids at the Sabina
takedown in 1972 when we took the first
aircraft down uh uh his brother's a
treasure and I think BB's got a ton of
strength lost grateful yeah yeah he lost
his brother who's a national treasur and
we're grateful for the United States and
the support and we're grateful for you
too Sean
yeah well our prayers are with you as
this Invasion now seems imminent and uh
God be with you thank you sir hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else